it's lindsey vaughn and her dog lucy
they're here
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah see they don't need to start to
leave
eucalyptus and you're such a tall drink
of water
and i am such a tiny one i wear these
deceptive shoes
i know i do the same thing but lucy come
up here lucy
you're part of this come here um they
met
lucy and lucy met before the show and
sniffed each other
yes they are acquainted and exactly
and they did their meet and greet and
found out that everything is super
kosher speaking of how tall you are
i couldn't believe you have to wear
men's skis
well i don't have to i actually want to
because they're better and
like faster and so i pushed the limits
and
no one else really did it before i did
it and then they're like you're crazy
and they're laughing at me and then i
won and then they're like oh maybe she's
on to something
do you think that they move faster do
they have a different type of ride and
speed and glide
uh they're stiffer they're more
difficult to turn
but if you can if you have the strength
to turn them then you actually can
generate more speed
so i always was trying to push the
limits and find new ways to be faster
and you know my tech my ski technician
used to work for bode miller and he's
like well
you know why don't we try some of these
skis and i was so much faster
right off the get and so that was that
was it
cowabunga something like that you know
i'm
reading about you and i'm thinking of my
own daughter
olive who is eight and she is the most
go for it kid which is
all you know you can never dream of as a
parent like she sees a giant wave and
she hurls herself into it
and she runs you know jump stairs and
she's just that fearless kid that's
awesome you can't teach that
really no you cannot teach that that's
what i feel like i mean i i have four
younger siblings
and none of them were like me i was
definitely different um and they were
you know
very motivated and and hardworking but
they just didn't they always had that
fear factor um i just i something maybe
is a miss
upstairs but i just don't get afraid um
at pretty much anything
i mean we've talked about fearless our
word of the week last week was intrepid
and it's all about being fearless and
then i question you know how do you get
to fearless
yeah i know that your grandfather was a
big influence on you and i was so
curious like
what did he say to you or your family
because i want to speak to her
in the right and inspiring way to help
aid her fearlessness
yeah and quell my own fears while i
watch
the most important thing in my universe
hurling herself into the abyss
um i mean it's basically just you know
i feel like my parents were never they
were never scared of me
doing things that were you know um
risky uh my grandparents were would
always pray for me when i skied but
they never said you know slow down or
you know this is too dangerous
my parents always encouraged me to
follow my dreams and they never
you know said that you know oh girls
don't do this or you know it was very
always very positive and if you want to
be the best you can be the best just
work hard at it
so i think it's just basically
encouraging them to to do what they want
to do because kids i think naturally
gravitate towards
their passions right if they're not
passionate about it they're definitely
not going to do it no matter what your
the parents say um but if they're
fearless that's
that's a great quality you have to tell
them
what can happen you know if something
goes wrong but if they're not afraid
that's
i mean i it's it's very difficult to
find people that
aren't naturally afraid of things okay
i'm gonna take that so that's a positive
okay very big i really i was like i want
to ask lindsey vonn
and you know her advice on having a
fearless child because my other daughter
is the exact opposite she's seeing
like the foam wash up and she's like
you know but that's natural like that's
kind of their personality and
you just got to encourage that and let
it grow now
okay the pack we have a vff wall
full of dog owners and dog lovers
we are dog owners and dog lovers please
tell me about this show i mean what a
dream like i know
travel the world with dogs yeah when
they approach me
amazon approached me i was you know
obviously retiring from my ski career
and they said do you want to do a global
competition show with lucy and
12 other dogs and i was like yes please
um
it was lit i mean who doesn't want to do
that um so lucy and i got to travel with
these amazing people
um they competed in different countries
for different challenges
lucy definitely would not have won any
of the challenges
i can confirm that but um it was very
fun and
we obviously enjoyed traveling she went
to the olympics with me in korea
so like lucy and i are inseparable and
this was like the perfect project for us
i think this is a dream show i think
it's going to be a huge hit because
people love to see
adventure competition shows but i've
never seen one like this with a partner
that is your dog yeah and i mean i am
going to be tuning in
this is so exciting in fact the pack
premieres tomorrow
friday november 20th on amazon prime
video
watch and celebrate the amazing bond
that we all have
they are family they are our best
friends and
lindsey vonn you have brought something
out into the world that i think all of
us are going to totally embrace
binge enjoy and just be so happy that
it's out there because this is so unique
and thank you for the life advice
because i want my daughter
to be fearless and i'm so in awe and
inspired of people like you that i had
to take the opportunity
to be a family member who enables their
daughters
to be fearless because i mean look at
you
well it sounds like you're doing a great
job so i'm sure she's going to be
amazing she already is amazing well i'm
going to follow your advice thank you so
much thank you lindsey vaughn and lucy
[Music]